- WELL, HELLO, WORLD.
THIS IS CATFISH COOLEY
COMING IN TO YOU LIVE.
GUESS WHAT DAY IT IS?
IT IS WHISKEY WEDNESDAY
HERE AGAIN.
IT'S WHISKEY WEDNESDAY, BABY.
WHISKEY.
WHOO!
I GOT NEWS FOR Y'ALL FOLKS.
WE HAVE A BLACK PRESIDENT.
RACISM IS DONE IN THIS COUNTRY.
IT WAS JUST A LITTLE BIT AGO
WHEN I FIGURED OUT
I WENT FULL RETARD.
LIVING LIFE AND LIVING WELL.
Y'ALL BE HAPPY AND GIVE IT HELL.
OH, BABY!
GET YOU SOME OF THAT!
[SNORTS]
- WHO KNEW YOU DIDN'T NEED
A FULLY FUNCTIONING LIVER
TO DO A BACK HANDSPRING?
THAT DOGGONE WALKING "HEE HAW"
EPISODE IS CATFISH COOLEY.
HE INVENTED WHISKEY WEDNESDAY
AND IS THE HAPPIEST REDNECK
S.O.B. YOU EVER DID MEET.
[SNORTS]
CATFISH HAS MADE HUNDREDS
OF MOTIVATIONAL VIDEOS,
AND IN EVERY SINGLE ONE,
HE WAS DRUNK AS A SKUNK.
DOESN'T MATTER IF YOU'RE
A REDNECK, HICK,
BUMPKIN, TRAILER TRASH,
TOOTHLESS MOUNTAIN CLOWN,
SISTER-FISTER, OR REPUBLICAN.
THEY ALL PUT THEIR
POINTY-HOODED ONESIES ON
ONE LEG AT A TIME.
THEY LIKE WRASSLIN', NASCAR,
AND HUNTIN'
BECAUSE THE SHADOW PEOPLE
DOMINATE THE BALL SPORTS.
REDNECKS ARE PROUD
TO BE AMERICAN
BECAUSE THEY LITERALLY HAVE
NOTHING ELSE TO BE PROUD OF.
HELL, IF IT WEREN'T
FOR BARBECUE,
WE'D BE BUILDING A WALL
AT THE MASON-DIXON LINE,
WHEREVER THAT IS.
BUT CATFISH COOLEY
HAS A MESSAGE TO SPREAD.
WHAT THAT MESSAGE IS,
I HAVE NO CLUE.
I JUST KNOW
IT WILL MAKE GREAT TV.
THAT'S WHY I HAD HIM
GET ON AN AEROPLANE
AND HIGHTAIL IT
TO THE LEFT COAST
FOR THIS WEEK'S
CE-WEB-RITY PROFILE.
I WOULDN'T BELIEVE IT
IF I DIDN'T SEE IT
WITH MY OWN TWO EYES.
CATFISH COOLEY
WALKING ON WATER
LIKE THE LORD HIMSELF.
- WHAT YOU TALKIN'
ABOUT, DANIEL?
AIN'T NO WATER OUT HERE.
IT'S DRIER THAN A TRISCUIT
ON A BISCUIT.
HELL, IT'S DRIER THAN ROSIE
O'DONNELL WATCHING "MAGIC MIKE."
- [LAUGHS]
IT'S DRIER THAN DRYER SHEETS
INSIDE THE DRYER ON--
NOT ON ECO MODE,
ON THE HIGH MODE.
I'M NEW AT BEING FOLKSY.
GET ON THE BOAT;
GRAB A POLE.
I LIKE FISHING OUT HERE.
NO WATER, NO SKEETERS.
THAT'S WHAT I SAY.
MAKES IT A LITTLE
MORE PRIVATE.
CATFISH, WHERE YOU FROM?
- I'M FROM PITKIN,
LOUISIANA, BROTHER.
- HOW OLD ARE YOU, CATFISH?
- 24.
- JESUS CHRIST.
- ACTUALLY, I'M 25.
I JUST HAD A BIRTHDAY.
[LAUGHS]
- WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
A HILLBILLY AND A REDNECK?
- HATS.
- HATS?
- HATS IS THE KEY.
YOU'RE A HILLBILLY;
I'M A REDNECK.
- HUH.
WHAT'S THE MOST REDNECK THING
YOU'VE EVER DONE?
- WELL, ACTUALLY,
MY PERSONAL VEHICLE I DROVE
FOR ABOUT THREE YEARS,
IT'S A 1989 AMIGO.
I RIPPED THE DOORS OFF OF IT.
I TOOK 2X4S, SCREWED THEM INTO
THE SIDE OF THE DASHBOARD,
SCREWED MY MIRRORS INTO THEM.
I SPRAY PAINTED IT
ABOUT 15 DIFFERENT COLORS,
AND BEFORE YOU ALWAYS
CRANKED IT, YOU HAD TO
POP THE HOOD OPEN AND POUR GAS
IN THE CARBURETOR.
[IMITATES TICKING NOISE]
[LAUGHING]
- HOW'D YOU GET
THE NAME CATFISH?
- I'VE ALWAYS BEEN A GYM RAT,
AND ONE DAY,
SOMEBODY JUST LOOKED AT ME,
AND HE STARTED CALLING ME
CATFISH COOLEY, YOU KNOW?
- EXPLAIN TO ME
WHY YOU MAKE PIG NOISES
WHEN YOUR NAME'S CATFISH.
- [SNORTS]
I ACTUALLY DON'T THINK
THAT'S A PIG NOISE.
- I APOLOGIZE.
WHAT IS IT?
- I LIKE TO THINK OF IT
AS A CATFISH NOISE,
BUT IT'S LIKE THE KING CATFISH
THAT YOU'VE NEVER HEARD BEFORE,
AND HE'S LIKE THE LEADER
OF ALL THE OTHER CATFISH.
[SNORTS]
- I NEED A NICKNAME.
TADPOLE.
- [LAUGHING]
I LIKE IT.
- I LIKE IT TOO. TADPOLE.
[HOWLING]
- PERFECT NOISE.
- SO YOU WORK OUT?
YOU TAKE PRIDE IN THE BODY?
- NAH, NO.
I JUST LIKE BEING STRONG.
- YOU DON'T DO CARDIO
IN YOUR WORKOUTS?
- HELL, NO.
I BARELY EVER PULLED OUT,
LET ALONE DOING A PILATE.
[LAUGHS]
- I'VE NEVER DONE A PILATE.
- ME NEITHER.
I'M ABOUT TO HAVE
MY FOURTH CHILD.
- YOU'RE ABOUT TO HAVE YOUR
FOURTH CHILD?
- FOURTH. MM-HMM.
- CATFISH.
- YOU WANT TO KNOW
WHO MY EX-WIFE IS WITH?
- WHO'S THAT?
- MY NEW WIFE'S OLD MAN.
- HOLD ON, I GOT TO GET
MY LOUISIANA BRAIN CAP ON.
YOUR EX-WIFE...
- IS WITH MY NEW WIFE'S
OLD MAN.
- YOU GUYS ALL GET ALONG?
- OH, NO.
THEY HATE US. WE HATE THEM.
WE ALL LOVE THE KIDS, THOUGH.
- WHAT'S YOUR WIFE'S NAME?
- WELL, WE CALL HER STINKBAIT.
- HOW'D SHE GET
THE NAME STINKBAIT?
- YOU GOT TO CATCH CATFISH
WITH SOMETHING.
- I TELL YOU WHAT;
MOST WOMEN I KNOW
DON'T LIKE THEIR NICKNAME
TO HAVE THE WORD "STINK" IN IT.
- NO, IT'S ALL RIGHT.
SHE KEEPS IT CLEAN.
- FAVORITE PART
OF THE WOMANLY BODY.
- THE BACK.
- WHY IS THAT?
- [LAUGHING]
YOU KNOW.
[LAUGHING]
- TALK ABOUT YOUR ANAL
EXPERIENCE AGAIN.
- OKAY, NOW, THAT--I KNEW
THAT WAS GONNA COME UP.
TO MAKE ME UNDERSTAND
WHAT'S REALLY GOING ON,
THEY GO AND THEY FIND THIS
LITTLE APPLICATOR,
LITTLE TAMPAX MINI PEARL,
TALKING ABOUT,
IF YOU CAN TAKE THIS LITTLE
INSERTION INTO THE RECTUM,
WE'LL GO ON
AND FULFILL THIS FANTASY.
- WHY'D IT BURN SO BAD?
- I DON'T KNOW.
- THAT DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE.
SHE MIGHT'VE DIPPED IT
IN HOT SAUCE.
- I'M TELLING YOU,
SHE HAD TO, BROTHER.
THE IDEA OF IT, IT WAS GONNA
JUST BE BING, BING, BAM,
YOU KNOW, WORTH IT IN THE END,
BUT HELL NO.
- SO YOU'RE DONE WITH
EXPERIMENTING IN THE BACKSIDE.
- WELL, I AIN'T COMPLETELY
PUTTING IT UP.
- OKAY, I MEAN, A PINKY BACK
THERE IS A NICE CUP OF COFFEE.
WHAT'S YOUR MOST POPULAR VIDEO?
- PROBABLY
THE LOVE-YOURSELF VIDEO
AND MY ORIGINAL-POWER-SHOT
VIDEO.
I DIDN'T EVEN DRINK IT YET,
AND I'M ALREADY
GETTING JACKED, BABY!
JESUS MONKEY [BLEEP]!
THAT'S AWESOME, BABY.
- DO YOU WORRY ABOUT
HOW MUCH YOU DRINK?
- OH, NO, I NEVER RUN OUT.
[BOTH LAUGHING]
- YOU GOT A LOT OF TATTOOS.
- YES, SIR.
- WHAT'S THE MOST EMBARRASSING
TATTOO YOU HAVE ON YOU?
- THE MOST EMBARRASSING TATTOO?
PROBABLY THE ONE I DONE MYSELF.
I TATTOOED A LITTLE DEVIL
WEARING A DIAPER,
HOLDING A PITCHFORK,
AND WAS REAL PROUD OF IT
TILL ABOUT THREE WEEKS LATER.
IT SAYS, "DOSENT
PLAY WELL WITH OTHERS."
[LAUGHS]
- THEY DON'T HAVE A SPELL CHECK
ON THE BODY.
- NONE WHATSOEVER.
- WILL THE SOUTH RISE AGAIN?
- I CLEARLY DOUBT IT.
- YOU EVER BEEN
WITH A BLACK WOMAN?
- UH, NO. NO.
- WELL...
WOULD YOU VOTE
FOR HILLARY CLINTON?
- NO, SIR.
SHE COULDN'T
KEEP HER HUSBAND HAPPY.
- YEAH.
THAT'S WHAT IT BOILS DOWN TO.
- MM-HMM.
- WHAT'S CATFISH'S
PHILOSOPHY ON LIFE?
- [BLEEP] IT.
[BOTH LAUGHING]
- WELL, CATFISH, IT'S CLEAR
TO ANYONE WITH A LICK OF SENSE
THAT YOU DESERVE TO BE ON TV,
AND I KNOW JUST THE SHOW
THAT WILL APPRECIATE YOUR
GOOD OLD-FASHIONED VALUES.
IT'S TIME TO GET CATFISH ADOPTED
BY AMERICA'S ROYAL FAMILY.
- [SNORTS]
- [HOWLS]
ALL RIGHT.
LETS' GET OUT OF HERE.
- LET'S GO, BROTHER.
- OH, GOL DANG IT!
I PUT THE FANS ON
BACKWARDS!
[CHEERY MUSIC]
- THERE'S NOT ONE PIC OF ME
ON THE FRIDGE.
- THIS SEASON ON "KEEPING UP
WITH THE KARDASHIANS,"
CATFISH COOLEY
MOVES INTO THE HOUSE.
- I DON'T KNOW WHY YOU GUYS
ARE EVEN FREAKING OUT
OR TALKING
ABOUT THIS, THOUGH.
- THE CALABASAS IS A [BLEEP]
[BLEEP]HOLE.
I'VE NEVER IN MY LIFE
SEEN SO MANY [BLEEP] ARMENIANS.
I DIDN'T EVEN KNOW WHAT THE HELL
AN ARMENIAN WAS
UNTIL I GOT HERE.
SOMETIMES I GET THE FEELING
THESE OLD GALS, THEY DON'T WANT
TO EVEN ACCEPT OLD CATFISH
AS PART OF THE FAMILY.
- THE HOUSE IS FILTHY,
AND THERE'S OPEN
BOTTLES OF ALCOHOL
SITTING ALL OVER THE COUNTER.
- IT'S WHISKEY WEDNESDAY, BABY.
[SNORTS]
IT AIN'T NEVER A BAD TIME
FOR A LITTLE KITCHEN WHITTLING.
[WHIRRING]
- OH, COME ON, NOW.
CAN'T Y'ALL GO SHAVE
THAT NOOKIE HAIR SOMEWHERE ELSE?
- OW!
- OH, MY GOD.
- WHAT?
- THIS IS HER DOG.
- OH, NO.
THAT DOG DIDN'T DO THAT.
THAT WAS KHLOE.
IF THAT KHLOE GAL
KEEP COMING IN HERE
AND BLOWING UP MY DAMN BATHROOM,
ME AND HER IS GONNA
HAVE SOME ISSUES.
OL' CATFISH IS COOKING SUPPER
TONIGHT, BUBBA.
HOO-HOO!
SMELLS LIKE KHLOE'S BRITCHES.
I AIN'T TRYING TO START [BLEEP],
BUT I WOKE UP
WITH THAT KANYE FELLER.
HE DONE CLOWNED UP MY DAMN BED,
SAYS HE WAS SLEEPWALKING.
BUT I KNOW GOOD AND WELL
HE WAS TRYING TO PLAY
WITH THAT OL' BUTTHOLE.
- ♪ BAH-BAH-BAH-BAAH ♪
- OL' CATFISH KNOWS SOMETHING
THAT'S GONNA TEAR
THIS FAMILY APART.
- I JUST WANTED TO TELL YOU
I AM PREGNANT.
- [SNORTS]
NOW, WHAT THE KARDASHIANS
NEED TO REMEMBER
IS STUFF IS JUST THINGS.
IT DON'T MAKE A [BLEEP] UNLESS
YOU OWN YOUR HAPPINESS.
AH, [BLEEP].
PANTS ARE TIED.
[MOANING]
- WHAT ARE WE WATCHING,
CATFISH?
- OH, JUST SOME HOME MOVIES
THERE, TADPOLE.
CHECK THAT OUT, BROTHER.
♪ ♪
- SHE LOOKED SO MUCH MORE
ETHNIC BACK THEN.
GROSS.
KIM.
JUST SUPPORTING
THE FAMILY BUSINESS.
- AIN'T NOTHING
TO BE ASHAMED OF.
LOVE KNOWS NO BOUNDARIES.
HELL, I TRIED ANAL ONCE.
- WE KNOW.
- [SNORTS]
[CHEERY MUSIC]
HE'S ONLY BEEN THERE FOR A WEEK,
AND THEY ALREADY LOVE HIM
MORE THAN ROB.